the uh the kyle rittenhouse trial
continues yesterday the prosecution now
this is the prosecution okay remember
that
they had richie mcginnis uh on on the
stand he's a daily caller reporter who
witnessed and filmed
what happened
that night there were not a lot of uh if
we were called during this in kenosha
and the riots all across the country in
2020
um
there were plenty of mainstream media
reporters on the scene
but uh they didn't they didn't see a lot
of the violence and chaos going on
because they were focused entirely on
the police
but richard mcginnis is one of the
reporters a real reporter on the scene
capturing what was happening
and um and he was a witness to what
happened with kyle rittenhouse and so he
was called in by the prosecution
and once again keep in mind this is the
prosecution's witness
and let's hear first i think we have a
couple of clips from him
um
he says first we'll play clip number two
where he talks about the sequence of
events and what led up to it here it is
the sequence of the folks that were
involved in this running as we've seen
in many other videos is mr rittenhouse
is uh in front mr rosenbaum is running
after him and you are behind mr
rosenbaum is that fair to say
yes how far back from mr rosenbaum were
you as the through as as the
pursuit went through the car source
parking lot
um well it's hard to say because i kind
of caught up to them
i was running a bit faster and so
uh at the time initially i was probably
30 feet back when the first when
everybody first started running but then
by the time i arrived in the lot it was
15 feet
and you continued to be behind mr
rosenbaum at the time that the defendant
shot and killed him correct
um i did alter my trajectory a little
bit um when i
saw mr rittenhouse turn around and saw
mr rosenbaum
um plunging for the front portion of the
rifle
let me stop you there for a second yeah
i bet you i bet you want to stop him
there
so rosenbaum the victim quote-unquote
this is this is the uh
the man that the prosecution wants to
portray as the victim you have your own
witness on the stand saying that that
that the quote-unquote victim lunged for
the rifle of kyle rittenhouse
the the defense has not even presented
its case yet
and already the prosecution case has
fallen apart and it got worse from there
there was this moment which was a dagger
for the prosecution only they're
stabbing themselves okay this is them
stabbing themselves with the dagger
um
and here just watch this exchange it's
pretty incredible
and you've already established that
after the shooting mr rosenbaum never
says it worked correct
correct
you don't know
as you sit here today
what mr rosenbaum was thinking do you
you mean at the time in the shooting yes
or at any point in his life i mean you
have no idea
what mr rosenbaum was ever thinking at
any point in his life you have never
been inside his head you never met him
before you don't i've never even i never
exchanged words with him if that's what
your question is
so your interpretation of what he was
trying to do or what he was intending to
do or anything along those lines is
complete guesswork isn't it um
well he said you and then he reached for
the weapon
let's talk about that
my god that's um that is one of those
that's like one of those moments that
you see in a
in a trial in a tv show or a movie
um
you know the only the only thing you
would add in if this was in a movie then
that would have there have been gasps
and everything in the in the um
among the people there in the courtroom
to add a little bit of dramatic flair
into it but it is a gasp moment where
uh
your
case just falls apart on the stand
so you have the quote unquote victim
saying out loud
you know stating his
violent intentions out loud you have him
lunging for the weapon
[Music]
and i have to keep emphasizing that
these are the witnesses the prosecution
is bringing up
we haven't even heard from the defense's
witnesses yet
there's there's simply no case here
we have video evidence
which should put an end to it right
there because we can all see what
happened
certainly we had all along we had one of
the the shootings
on video
and you could very clearly see
that kyle rittenhouse is on the ground
and then he's got this mob of violent
people who are about to pounce on him
and then we had most of the other
shooting on the video and then we find
out later that the feds had the rest of
of of that video they didn't tell us
about it and we didn't see it until
right now
and on top of the video evidence we also
now have eyewitnesses the prosecution's
eyewitnesses the state's eyewitnesses
who
uh are painting a picture of events that
entirely vindicates kyle writtenhouse
so when you see this and you listen to
what these witnesses have to say and you
watch the video
and you listen to the the state's
opening arguments and everything that
they presented
before the trial and during the trial so
far
and you see that they they
just have no case at all against this
guy
there is nothing there
now does that mean that written house
will actually walk
no because you never know what a jury
will do
and all it really takes is one antifa
sympathizer on that on that jury which
that could very easily be or more than
one
it only takes one blm sympathizer
there could very easily be one or more
than one
but uh
chances are
kyle riddenhaus certainly he deserves to
walk and i would say chances are that he
actually does
you know because it
this is so
incontrovertible it's so unavoidable the
facts are right there
as far as self-defense claims go
this is
about as
straightforward and simple as it gets
there are times when self-defense claims
are a little bit more complicated
there can obviously be gray areas
in situations like this but here there
is not
and that's why
all along
the people calling for kyle
rittenhouse's head
they're not really talking about the
shootings themselves
what you hear and this is including the
prosecution's case
what what they keep going back to
and certainly what you hear online all
the time with the the outraged mob
online saying kyle rittenhouse should be
in jail he should be executed all these
things people who are otherwise are very
much opposed to
supposedly
opposed to the death penalty but in this
case they'll make they'll make an
exception for kyle reynolds because he's
white
um
but what they keep saying is well he
shouldn't have been there to begin with
he he he crossed state lines
so what what difference does that make
so you cross state lines and now you
don't have a right to self-defense
anymore
so i live in tennessee if i go to
virginia and someone tries to kill me i
can't shoot them because i cross state
lines
coming by the way from people who don't
care about about lines they say that
lines are borders boundaries these are
imaginary boundaries
they say there's no significance to the
boundary separating the united states
from mexico
and anybody who lives
south of our of our southern border they
have every right to come here and enjoy
all of the freedoms and liberties and
entitlements that we enjoy as american
citizens including the right to vote
and now even uh we're going to be paying
off you know
giving out 450 thousand dollar checks
for the buy administration to these
immigrants as well so they'll say that's
fine because the border is imaginary
and yet the border separating a state
one state from another
is this
is this like this magical boundary
and once you cross it if you don't
belong to that state you have no right
to self-defense that's
the claim
well of course that's the claim for
people who have no principles whatsoever
they feel no need to be honest
they feel no obligation
to the truth whatsoever
um
and then as far as him oh he wasn't
supposed to be there
nobody was supposed to be there
like nothing
none of the events
kenosha that night should have been
occurring
you had mobs of people burning down the
city none of that should have been
happening
so at worst
you would say kyle rittenhouse
just like the other 50 000 people
didn't shouldn't have been there
rosenbaum the victim shouldn't have been
there
um
that's at worst like that's the worst
thing you could say about kyle
rittenhouse but i wouldn't even really
agree with that
because he worked in kenosha that was
that was his community as well
as someone who spent a lot of time there
he was helping to clean up graffiti
earlier in the day he actually cared
about the community
and he felt an obligation to go there
and
and do what law enforcement would not do
and when law enforcement refuses to do
its job or is not allowed to do its job
or some combination of the two
then you're going to have some citizens
who feel called to step in and fill that
gap that's what called right now did
but whether he should or should not have
done that whether he should or should
not have been there whatever that means
he still has a basic right to
self-defense
and that's very clear so then you have
to start asking yourself
considering that there's no case at all
here
and the state knows that they have no
case
okay they're not crazy they know there's
no case here
there's a reason why they had to bring
uh richie mcginnis up because they don't
have anybody else
so then you really have to ask what what
what are they trying to achieve here
you have to start asking yourself
do they want more riots is that what
this is about
because you're going to get them
once he's exonerated which which he
probably will be
you're going to have mass riots against
kenosha
antifa and blm they've already promised
that they've stated that ahead of time
if you don't convict this guy we're
going to riot
they are trying to coax a guilty verdict
just like they did
with derek chovin by threatening
violence and implicitly threatening it
against the jurors as well if they don't
get what they want
implicitly and also in some cases
explicitly
so is that the point in the end the the
powers that be here do they do they want
more riots and more chaos in the streets
you really have to start wondering about
that
i mean you could also theorize the other
way and say that they well they're
trying to appease the mob and that's the
reason they arrested and charged them to
begin with
but they would also have to know that
this appeasement is very temporary
i mean there would have been additional
rioting had they never charged him at
all
but that would have all happened back
last summer when when they were rioting
anyway
so they could have said right then look
there's no case here this is
self-defense we're not going to charge
him
uh the left would have been very upset
about it there would have been
you
know it would it would have put some
more literal fuel on the fire but it's a
fire that was already burning at that
point
and we would have all long since moved
on by now
now what you've guaranteed once he's
exonerated is that you're going to have
mass rioting
along the lines of what we saw last
summer if not worse
is that the intention is that what they
actually want
again you have to have to really wonder
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends